very you're so handsome Oh Chris go on
oh okay like also you're super good at
opening boxes finding stuff inside
people say that about me and now I get
to prove it because I'm gonna show you
my collection box today
all right Bordeaux is a handsome
collection $400 claptrap in a box
edition it's unboxing time let's go
little bit all right oh you open it up
and what do you see little psycho face
little gold-plated blue-eyed psycho face
dripping with I guess gold gold psycho
goo yeah who's on the back none other
than the handsome man himself the
handsome handsome jack so that's the
actual game the game this is the xbox
one copy it comes with Borderlands 2 all
the borderlands 2 DLC which is like a
crap ton of DLC Borderlands the
pre-sequel and also all the DLC for that
that's been included in the season pass
those far including clap tastic voyage
then DLC that's coming out on March 24th
which is when this thing comes out
that's great so you're like completely
caught up with everything and even
includes like the level cap so you're
getting with everything if you haven't
gotten it before you know like the
cosmetic stuff like the new costumes and
colorations and stuff that's right you
toss that piece of cardboard away and
like what box inside of a box look at
the box in this box yeah we got we got
boxes and boxes boxes on boxes
oh wait that's like a folder all right
I'm gonna be really cautious check this
thing out
unsealing this Marriot hyped up your box
opening abilities earlier don't let me
know I'm known for it because it's so
perfect it's a piece of paper kidding
these are the protecting paper for the
lithographs these are cool I believe it
comes with 12 that makes sense that's
the vault hunters I believe so it's you
know it starts out we got the
borderlands 2 Axton Maya and all the
door zero-zero we've got gage will deal
see action as well as krieg the psycho
you got a half clap chop sticks are cool
areas he looks he's showing off his
muscles huge Athena looking super boss
where she has a sword she's got a shield
can't have a shield a sword
you got Wilhelm Ganesha the law bringer
you got handsome jack and the latest DLC
character for the pre-sequel bill
Baroness nice little highway Darius
container and I feel like this is gonna
be the PSD resistance if you will oh the
claptrap itself the claptrap the titular
crap claptrap in a box okay help got the
right now stuff I don't expect you to
have the same skills I have no I'll just
get it started and then you can finish
it up
so yeah this claptrap it's like an art
it's a remote control claptrap that you
can actually like zip around and
presumably it says annoying quips to
people that it encounters I would expect
nothing less
we're gonna test about famous phrases
including stairs no because he's not a
wheel Oh glad that is it Gardevoir all
right oh this is sweet actually yeah
this is a sweet so this is like the
styrofoam casing but it does look like
says claptrap on it with Hyperion so it
looks like you actually are buying it
from the company itself here we go
he looks great all right we cut the
friggin claptrap holy crap
this thing is real his arms are not
attached not yet they're not okay
yeah that's mostly yeah here we go it
didn't like click or anything but it
didn't they move and they've got all the
bendy bit there poseable and here is a
small stick it presumably goes on his
head top base yeah and then with the
four awesome is that it does come with a
nap
it comes with a nap so we should go
ahead and test this bad boy out
I mean we have to drive the clock trap
that's not you can't unbox clock trap
without driving it let's drive
well you're a little [ __ ] up buddy hey
what's up there is an instruction manual
really easy to pair connects over Wi-Fi
it's got two settings one is to run like
so and one is just to display and it
does weird little lights and stuff like
that
Mary is controlling it using her Android
app nice little nice little dance moves
pretty solid
the arms are there poseable but they're
not part of the remote control operation
it's just the wheel but like this thing
is bouncing really well his eye really
is an eye and I can see what he sees so
if I move him over here
alright I'm going I'm gonna go down the
hallway there's Ben go get Ben can tap a
button to make your voice go through the
clock trap and into Ben can you hear me
we have confirmation they can hear us
redditors bonuses battle bot